Imperial flags rain across the galaxy
can you be trusted without your shackles
let's just get this over with shall we
we've a mission for you
a major weapons test is imminent we need
to know how to destroy
if you're really doing this I want to
help
[Music]
good
I've been recruiting through the
rebellion for a long time we destroyed
our aside the Empire now
I fear nothing all is as the force will
stir
the captain says you are a friend I will
not kill you
thanks there is a much time every day
they grow stronger
there is a 97.6% chance of failure
it means well
this is our chance to make real
difference
are you with me
all the way
[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie so we finally
got our Darth Vader Star Wars rogue one
trailer so let's break it down they
totally did the spider-man Civil War
thing but it's both Disney so you
understand like they keep him to the
very end of the trailer we finally got
to see Darth Vader rise lord Vader even
though it was just breathing I love the
color palette too like they have all the
green in the rebels base with Mon Mothma
ears they drag her and then you have red
for Darth Vader the whole theme song of
the trailer was based on the Imperial
March like the whole idea is that the
Empire is reaching its height of power
the rebellion hasn't quite formed yet
there are still a number of splinter
cells so even though a lot of the
characters that are forming this Ocean's
eleven team to go steal the Death Star
plans are part of the rebellion they're
not necessarily part of the same cells
there's no unifying force like you see
in the original trilogy and for those
that are confused if you can't tell by
the designs in the trailer this takes
place between Episode three after Anakin
fully becomes Darth Vader in before
Episode four where we meet Luke
Skywalker for the first time so the
whole idea of this movie is that we're
looking at a corner of the Star Wars
universe at a really big event from a
different perspective something that we
wouldn't normally see in the main films
because those are largely dedicated to
following the Skywalker family and even
though this guy you know via Darth Vader
the Skywalker family is a part of this
he's not necessarily the biggest
character in the film he's just kind of
floating in the background the actor who
plays director cranek the person in the
the Grand Admiral white-looking uniform
he says that he's the big bad Darth
Vader is just swirling in the background
in one detail that I really like about
the Death Star is that the laser is on
the bottom side like the sphere it's
almost like it's turned upside down but
when you think about it if the Death
Star were actually sitting above a
planet the laser would be firing down
anyway so that would be the correct way
for it to sit but it just it looks
really cool when it's right side up and
when you're in space like if you want to
get really technical about it because
there's no gravity it really doesn't
matter what position your ship is in
that you're on as long as there's
gravity on that ship binding you to the
floor so you've already met all these
rebel characters you know who the
protagonists are but there's a lot more
dialogue in this trailer he had a better
sense for jyn erso relationship with the
rebellion even though she hates the
Empire she wasn't necessarily part of
the rebellion before this but she's a
troublemaker she has a very liam neeson
a particular set of skills that they
in order to get the Death Star plan so
it sounds like she's got something
really bad gets arrested by them and
they offer her this deal like look you
hate the Empire we hate the Empire
you're in big trouble we can help you
out but you have to go steal these plans
for us so I do really like the idea of
more complicated heroes because it's a
much more believable take on the
characters like everybody in the galaxy
isn't all good or all bad it's all just
like shades of grey so in that spirit
you have alan tudyk character the droid
that he's playing he's probably gonna be
one of the best things about this movie
he's kind of like an assassin typed or
something that you might see standing
next to a g88
when Darth Vader hires all those bounty
hunters during Empire Strikes Back but
he's been repurposed by the rebels but
he hasn't lost any of his attitude so
he's got that surly r2d2 attitude but he
has the ability to speak so he can just
tell you that he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he's gonna be like the Rocket Raccoon of
the group just the person who just says
the most awful things imaginable and
just winds up being hilarious so he
wasn't in the trailer but the other
really big new thing that they revealed
is that Bail Organa Jimmy Smits is
coming back you know from the prequels
as Bail Organa because he was still
alive during this time he presumably
died when Alderaan was destroyed by the
Death Star so the you know the
interesting thing and I think I talked
about this during my teaser video is
that this is one of those movies where
you kind of already know where the story
ends up like we know what happens during
Episode four so we know that they get
the plan so it's not so much about
surprise like even though Darth Vader's
a big surprise that they put him in this
movie but the real fun of this is going
to be the suspense so that's really what
they're leaning on plus you have the
thread of Darth Vader I'll be interested
to see if he pops his lightsaber in the
film or if he just walks around looking
really menacing choking people through
their TVs but you do get the sense from
the rest of the empire that they don't
necessarily hold him in high regard they
are afraid of him but then there's other
leadership in the military that just
won't have absolutely nothing to do with
them they don't even care about the four
pick everybody thinks that the Jedi has
died off the forces some myths some old
wives tale so then Darth Vader has to
show you the power of the force so I'll
be interested to see how they invoke a
very you know power of the force moment
like it's all about belief so Donnie
yen's character is like the very
spiritual force user he's I don't think
he's supposed to be a Jedi but he's a
force user so I think a lot of that
wisdom is gonna come through him so I'll
be interested to see if he has like a
Yoda type moment where he's
like let go of your anger like over your
hate and some big miraculous force event
happens but I am expecting Darth Vader
to do very Darth Vader II things so let
me know in the comments even though we
know what the plot is going to be
because we've all seen the other Star
Wars movies so we know how it ends up
what do you think the big surprises of
the movie are going to be like what do
you think that Darth Vader is going to
do in the film to make everyone's heads
explode in the movie theater just like
oh my god that was so amazing they kind
of tease like a Luke Skywalker atat
moment like when he took down the 8080
Walker when they have the bazooka but
the difference here is that none of
these people are ringers like Luke was
they're not as strong in the force
they're just gonna be like a real down
dirty Star Wars fight that looks like a
classic Star Wars movie that's what I'm
most excited about - it looks like the
special effects have been polished a lot
since they released the last trailer so
I'm really excited for this if you guys
didn't know it's coming out in December
so they'll probably be another big
trailer with even more Darth Vader in it
I don't know if we're gonna see the
Emperor Darth Vader was really like the
only other big dark side force user that
we heard about in the movie and or Seok
Renick is really more of like the Grand
Moff Tarkin of the movie so I think the
Emperor's presence in the movie is gonna
be a lot like it was in the first Star
Wars movie like he existed people talked
about him but he didn't really see him
so what's gonna happen next is it was a
whole bunch of comic book news that I
didn't get to today so I'll be posting a
bunch of videos for that next but if
there's any other Star Wars videos that
you guys want just let me know in the
comments so while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for my Star Wars Episode 8 teaser video
and you can click here to learn all
about what's going on in the flash
season 3 thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]